la siguiente tabla de contingencia de
frecuencia muestra datos sobre el
tratamiento y el resultado de ataques
cardíacos para los participantes de un
estudio longitudinal realizado por el
doctor randy cuáles de las siguientes
son conclusiones válidas elige todas las
opciones correctas veamos primero
nuestra tabla de contingencia aquí están
las personas que tuvieron un ataque
cardíaco de aquellas personas que
tuvieron un ataque cardíaco
nos dicen que 12 estaban tomando placebo
es decir no estaban tomando alguna
medicina y siete del total de todas
estas estaban tomando aspirinas de
aquellas personas que no tuvieron un
ataque cardíaco
nos dicen que 421 de estas del total
estaban tomando placebos y 442 que no
tuvieron ataque cardíaco estaban tomando
aspirina
y es lo que podemos deducir de esto la
primera opción más participantes
recibieron un placebo que aspirina bueno
vemos aquí contamos quienes recibieron
placebo es sumar estas dos columnas 421
+ 12 van a ser 433 y en cambio los que
tomaron aspirinas son 442 7 son 400 49
casi 450 fueron más personas las que
estuvieron tomando aspirinas de las que
estuvieron tomando un placebo así que
ésta de que más participantes recibieron
un placebo que aspirina no es correcta
veamos la siguiente 12 de los 433
participantes que recibieron un placebo
tuvieron un ataque cardiaco veamos la
tabla nos dicen que 12 de los 433
participantes que recibieron un placebo
esta es la columna de los que recibieron
placebo para saber el total tenemos que
sumar estos dos valores
de los que tuvieron un ataque cardíaco
como de los que no lo tuvieron son 12
421 ya habíamos comentado que son 433
433 es el número total de aquellas
personas que tomaron placebo en este
estudio y 12 de ellos tuvieron un ataque
cardíaco así que esta 12 de los 433
participantes que recibieron un placebo
tuvieron un ataque cardíaco ésta sí es
una opción correcta la última es ninguna
de las anteriores bueno ésta no es
correcta ya que vimos que esta si es
correcta vamos a verificar nuestra
respuesta
en efecto es correcta